let's get to audience questions for the
week first one from Felicia Felicia says
hey David you seem to read quite a bit
I've been out of reading for a long time
what are some books you would recommend
that would get people back into reading
depends on whether you're talking
fiction or nonfiction it depends on the
genre also if for nonfiction find an
area that you're curious about and get
see what the top books are in that under
that topic of nonfiction and just grab
one or two that would be my
recommendation for fiction it really
depends on the genre right I mean if you
like science fiction I would say get
some arthur c clarke books 2001 a space
odyssey is a good one to start with
philip k dick endless books by fili
philip k dick if you're interested in
time-travel type stuff I really like the
two book series by Connie Willis black
out followed by all clear dark matter by
Blake Crouch that's newer sci-fi that I
think is good those are some options
there's really endless options if you're
into or want to explore cyberpunk which
is sort of a subset of science fiction I
say start with Neil Stevenson Snoke Snow
Crash or maybe Neuromancer by William
Gibson that's a good option if you want
to try something more classic and maybe
like a darker crime fiction type of
thing I really like Raymond Chandler
eric ambler and Agatha Christie has a
very very long list of books that would
be great spy fiction one of my favorite
authors is John Lake array of course the
pen name of David Cornwall Cornwall are
Cornwell I forgot now anyway John Lake a
rat everything from spy who came in from
the cold
the constant gardener the tailor of
Panama he just has a new book out which
I bought but haven't read yet he is an
absolute classic author and if you're
looking for like an exciting page-turner
I really like Robert Ludlum's Bourne
trilogy which was eventually turned into
the movies right Damon the Bourne
Identity The Bourne Supremacy and The
Bourne Ultimatum or I don't remember
exactly what they were but the original
books there's been a ton of books
written with the Bourne character but
I'm talking about Rob
lud limbs original three and then lastly
if you like historical fiction I like
Alan first fu rst he lived in Paris for
quite some time and he writes really
great historical fiction taking place a
lot of the stories take place in France
but some of them are in Spain some of
them are in Poland and different places
during mostly the Second World War and
really really good historical fiction so
it really depends on the genre Wow okay
so it sounds like the person writing in
is trying to get back into readings yes
with some of those suggestions are they
maybe shorter books may be easy reads
because they're trying to get themselves
acclimated you see I think that they are
all if you choose the right genre and
story for you whether it's long or short
it should suck you in okay I think that
people who are just looking for a short
book to get back in look for a book
where the story appeals to you well I
was thinking you know maybe go back to
some of the books that you read in high
school or college that were absolute
page-turners from you and if it's been a
little while you can reread those and
still you know have the same excitement
that you had the first time around yeah
when that may be back into it something
like that maybe one of those dystopian
novels I've not gone back to Beowulf I
do not enjoy Beowulf when I was fourteen
and I don't know if I want to go back to
Beowulf but 1984 I have reread and
Fahrenheit 451 I've reread you know in
the last 10 years or so
yeah I'm wrapping up brave new world
right now oh it also lassika I would
recommend maybe Kurt Vonnegut oh yes I
mean I love his storytelling style I
mean the fact that a narrator can just
introduce themselves as one of the
characters halfway through the book yeah
it's phenomenal to me and it has
pictures can't go wrong with pictures
sure that's it that'll smooth the
transition from comic books into books
that's always a good good recommendation
from producer Pat there to make that
transition really smooth okay there are
some ideas there's there's there's
endless books to read right I mean my
list of books I'd like to read is over a
hundred long right now and I've got
three on my nightstand so it's it's an
uphill battle